Hi everyone.
It is a great pleasure to be
delivering this geometric deep learning
course to the African Master of Machine
Intelligence for a second year in a row.
Um, you haven't actually had a chance to
formally meet me yet. My name is Petar.
I'm a staff research scientist at
DeepMind and an affiliated lecturer at
the University of Cambridge.
And
during the two lecture medley that we're
going to have today, we are going to
chat about some aspects of the geometric
deep learning blueprint as it applies to
broadly speaking graphs and sets. But I
do hope that uh throughout my
discussions today and maybe throughout
some lectures you will see afterwards,
uh you will come out having the
impression that to an extent uh whenever
we're doing deep learning on
classical computers, we are always to an
extent doing some kind of deep learning
on graphs and sets. So, it's a big ask.
Let's see how far we can take it.
Um
So, just to give you a bit of a recap
from what you've seen in previous
lectures,
we've seen how to take basically a small
set of guiding principles like
symmetries, group equivariance, group
invariance, locality, and scale
separation, and broadly speaking use
those principles to synthesize and steer
the design of deep learning
architectures, right? So, previous
lectures have hopefully showed you why
it's a good idea to do so and maybe on a
general level how to do it. But we
haven't talked about anything specific
yet. And if you probably remember this
figure from the previous lectures, which
shows that you could in principle
construct any architecture that you care
about through a combination of
equivariant layers, nonlinearities,
pooling layers, and invariant layers if
you need to predict something on the
level of the entire domain.
Now, in our book and our course, we
claim maybe somewhat bombastically that
this is all you need to build the
architectures you need.
And
once again here, you just have a recap
of what those elements of the of the
architectures are.
So, you have linear G-equivariant
layers, pointwise nonlinearities, local
pooling, and G-invariant layers. All of
these concepts should be reasonably
familiar from the previous lectures.
Uh but specifically, what we show and
what we hope to guide you through in
these lecture series is that you can
basically
of your popular favorite architecture
like ConvNets, graph neural nets, deep
sets, transformers, some of which you've
probably seen in previous courses in
this
master series, um and basically express
them using our blueprint just by
choosing the right domain and the right
symmetry group to be to be aligned to.
Uh however, obviously we haven't seen
any very concrete examples of this yet.
And in this lecture, we're actually
going to cover already three of the
architectures that you see in the table
here. We'll be covering graph neural
networks, deep sets, and transformers,
which all encode some aspect of
permutation symmetry over a set domain
or a graph domain as it turns out. Now,
some of these things might sound a
little bit strange because you might
have heard about transformers as a
sequence model primarily, but I do hope
that by the end of today's two lectures,
you will be able to get a proper feel
how transformers fit inside our picture.
So, you might also be asking yourself,
why do we start with graphs, right? If
you've done any kind of deep learning
course before this, you probably
wouldn't expect to start by learning
about graphs.
However, we have very good reasons for
why we want to start with learning on
graphs. Graphs and sets provide us a
very convenient discrete domain, and
there's basically very little geometric
assumptions on these domains. So, we
just have resistance to permutations.
This will make it very easy to analyze
the architectures. And also, pretty much
everything that follows in future
lectures will be expressible using the
blueprint you learned today. Okay?
And it's hard to understate just how
close this connection is because for
many years, when you said geometric deep
learning, it was basically synonymous
with representation learning on graphs.
So, there's a very good historical and
generalist motivation to start with
graphs, and also it's arguably the
easiest one to introduce from the
perspective of the blueprint because the
symmetries are not particularly
restrictive.
And there is very good reason why you
might want to study data that lives on
graphs because when you think about it,
graphs are pretty much all around us. We
can find them at all levels of
organization in the uh living world
starting from the basic building blocks
of organisms, the organic molecules,
which are best represented as graphs of
atoms connected together by chemical
bonds,
all the way up to the organizations of
the neurons in the human brain, which
guide our cognition processes, where you
can imagine different neurons connected
together in an interconnected network
known as the connectome.
Uh but beyond naturalistic phenomena, we
can also use graphs to explain all kinds
of human and social constructs uh from
transportation networks. Here you have a
slightly outdated
um visualization of the London Tube map,
where you can imagine nodes as different
intersections and edges as different
connections between them. And also
social network like this Facebook
friendship graph that's illustrated at
the bottom right, where you can imagine
different humans and users as nodes in a
graph and their friendship connections
as edges. So, basically graphs are
pretty much all around us. And uh
um recently especially, people are
starting to realize just how pervasive
graphs are and how they might be the
modality that truly reflects the
underlying data that you're trying to
deal with.
And as a result, across both science and
industry, they are starting to become
more and more ubiquitous particularly
through the graph neural network, which
is the canonical method for processing
data that lives on graphs.
And this is just a sample of some of the
things that graph neural networks have
been capable of doing.
They have been used to discover powerful
antibiotics.
Uh they have been used to
power the next generation of chip
design, uh which is quite an interesting
meta-argument because now AI is being
used to aid the process of synthesizing
a chip that will be used to execute AI,
which is a very nice kind of circular
argument. Uh beyond that, virtually uh
all the companies that deal with
large-scale
interconnected data are now realizing
the power of graph neural networks. Here
I've highlighted only the example of
Uber Eats that uses graph neural
networks to recommend which food you
should eat next. But beyond Uber Eats,
uh
uh many key industry players like Amazon
and Airbnb and Pinterest are using graph
neural networks as well.
In a nutshell, to serve you
recommendations, which products you
should buy next, which content you
should view next, which places you
should stay at next. So, it's kind of
a very natural um a very natural way of
of analyzing this kind of data.
And maybe something that's a bit more
closer to my personal claim to fame, uh
as I said, you can also view
transportation networks as a sort of
interconnected graph structure. And as
part of a team at DeepMind,
I worked on developing and deploying one
of these graph neural networks inside
the Google Maps, and it's now deployed
worldwide. So, whenever you ask Google
Maps for the optimal route from A to B,
the actual travel time prediction that's
served to you is computed by a graph
neural network that we have developed
here at DeepMind.
And when you really think about it, I've
given you many examples of naturally
occurring data that's best represented
as a graph, you might try to extrapolate
from there and just say in many ways,
graphs are the main
modality of data that we receive from
by this quote from Jay Wright Forrester,
uh essentially, you can also think of uh
uh concepts, relationships between those
concepts, and the processes that lead to
us deriving new knowledge as effectively
a graph structured reasoning process.
What this means for us is that if we're
ever going to build artificial general
intelligence, it is quite unlikely we
will able to build it without some
aspect of graph representation learning
simply because how critical it is uh in
expressing the way cognition works. So,
basically speaking, no matter what area
of science or industry you choose to
specialize in, there is a good chance
you will come into contact with graph
representation learning, and that's why
it's generally a good idea to study it.
And maybe I should also mention that uh
quite recently, methods powered by graph
neural networks have been able to make
significant scientific strides to the
point where they have been also featured
on the cover of Nature. I participated
in this collaboration alongside several
DeepMinders and pure mathematicians,
where we showed that these graph neural
networks are capable of detecting
interesting structure inside complicated
mathematical objects. And using this
structure, our mathematician
collaborators have been able to derive
top-tier results in very distinct areas
of mathematics such as knot theory and
representation theory. And this
achievement was recognized both by
Nature, where it graced the cover page a
few months ago, and also by many popular
press outlets such as the New Scientist.
Uh at this point, you might be curious
to find out more about the
mathematician's view into all of this,
and I'm very delighted to say that we
have secured Jordi Williamson, our MATS
collaborator from the University of
Sydney, to give a guest lecture in this
course. And in my opinion, it is not to
be missed because it will also offer you
a mathematician's very pure view into
all of this geometric deep learning
stuff that we have been trying to build
up over the past few lectures.
So, hopefully in these past few slides,
I've convinced you that it's a good idea
to study data that lives on graphs.
So, now that you're hopefully convinced,
uh you might be asking yourselves, where
do we begin? How do we begin to build
this theoretical framework?
Well, I'm actually going to start by a
potentially disappointing premise in
that I'm going to first look at graphs
that don't have any edges between them,
i.e., unordered sets.
And why do we start with just sets?
Well, there's a few good reasons why we
might want to do that. First of all,
because we only have to worry about the
nodes and not worry about the
connections between them, sets are going
to be just generally much simpler to
mathematically analyze.
However, even though they're simpler to
analyze, once we draw our conclusions on
sets, most of them will very naturally
carry over to graphs, so it won't be
wasted work to start with sets. And even
if you restrict yourself to processing
data that lives on sets, you are still
solving problems that could be very
practically relevant. For example, many
data that's relevant to computer vision
comes in a form of point clouds, where
you have to classify objects based on
their point cloud structure, as you can
see here on the left. But also, in many
real-world important applications such
as self-driving vehicles, you need to
make sense of the world around you not
from two-dimensional images, but from
actually point cloud representations of
the objects around you. So, a typical
self-driving vehicle will use these
lidar sensors to compute a bunch of
these points uh of where the sensor
bounces off of nearby objects, and based
on off of those uh
uh point representations, you need to
infer what are the objects around the
car, how fast are they moving, and so
on, so that the car can then make
actionable decisions for itself.
So, hopefully it's a good enough
motivation for us to start this
investigation from learning on sets. And
uh okay, so let's begin. We're going to
start off by assuming we have a graph
with no edges. What does this mean from
the perspective of the geometric deep
learning blueprint? Our domain omega is
equal to just a set of nodes V. Okay?
So, these are the nodes on which our
data is going to live, and typically,
since we're doing deep learning, we want
to featurize those nodes.
So, we can say that every single node
has some feature vector attached to it.
We're going to call that vector xi for
the features of node i that are in this
case assumed to be k-dimensional real
vectors.
So, what this means is that our feature
space C from the geometric deep learning
blueprint is equal to uh R to the K.
And once we have features for every
node, we need to find some way to
present them to a deep learning model.
The canonical way in which that is done
is to just stack these node features
into a node feature matrix. So, you
build a a matrix capital X, which is
basically a matrix with
number of rows equal to the number of
nodes and number of columns equal to the
number of feature dimensions, and then
the ith row of that matrix will
correspond to the features of ith node.
This should all feel very familiar
because it's the standard method in GDL
to build a a discrete signal.
And one very important thing to note
here is that the very act of you doing
this, like the very act of you stacking
node features into a matrix, has already
done something controversial. You have
specified an ordering of the nodes,
right? And as we said at the beginning,
we assume our sets to be completely
unordered, right? So, what we really
want is the result of any neural network
or any function applied to these set
features to not depend on the decision
you made on how to stack them. So, let's
try to pictorially represent this. What
do we want? Let's imagine I have a set
of five nodes, and I have features in
every single one of them. And naturally,
I might be interested in learning some
kind of a function, some kind of a
neural network that takes this
collection of five objects and predicts
some label, right? But what I then want
is if I choose to change the way in
which you see these five objects,
perhaps by changing their order or
something like that,
I would still want my neural network to
give me exactly the same answer. Okay?
So, this kind of rigorous enforcing of
giving the same answer no matter how I
choose to present you these objects is
exactly the symmetry that we want to
capture when we build our neural
networks for sets. In the language of
geometric deep learning,
the symmetry group that we care about is
the n-element permutation group sigma n.
And the group elements G of this
permutation group are permutations. Now,
I'll try to elaborate on this a bit
further in a few slides' time.
So, specifically, because we want to
talk about uh
uh being resistant to how these nodes
are presented to you, what's the order
in this node feature matrix,
it will be very useful for us to be able
to think about the operations that
change the order of the nodes.
And as you might know from
combinatorics, these operations are
known as permutations. For a collection
of n elements, there are n factorial
many of them.
And uh this is just one example of a
permutation, uh well, one pictorial
example and one in text, that show how
you can take a collection of objects and
then apply a permutation transformation,
which just changes the order in which
you see them, but fundamentally, it is
still the same collection of objects.
And this is a way of saying that
permutations can encode a very useful
symmetry that we might want to capture.
Now, one thing that's very convenient
for us is that when you're talking about
permutation operations,
we can actually completely reason about
them in the realms of linear algebra,
which is very useful because deep
learning is typically defined in the
world of linear algebra. So,
in fact, every single permutation of n
objects defines a unique n by n matrix,
which are some which is sometimes known
as a permutation matrix.
And here you can see one example of a
permutation matrix for the permutation
2413, and you can hopefully kind of make
out what's going on, right? They're
matrices that have zeros almost
everywhere. They have exactly one one in
every row and every column. And the only
effect that these permutation matrices
have is that when you left multiply them
with our node feature matrix as before,
the only effect it has is to permute the
order of the rows. So, it encodes
exactly the operation we want to be
resistant to and nothing else. Now, if
you can recall what we discussed in
previous lectures on the geometric deep
learning blueprint, you can then
immediately immediately relate this
permutation matrix as a real
representation of the permutation group
action or the row of G as it was
abstractly
uh discussed in previous lectures. So,
in this case, G might be a permutation
like 2413, and row of G takes that
permutation and gives you a matrix like
this, which has the appropriate effect
when you multiply it with your node
features representations.
And now we can basically just directly
apply uh the blueprint of for example,
G-invariance
to derive the necessary condition of our
function to be satisfactory when working
over sets, right? Cuz as we said at the
beginning, we want functions that
operate over these node feature matrices
such that they will not depend on the
order of the rows.
What does this mean equivalently and
following the definition of
G-invariance? When you apply a
change the result. And this directly
gives us a very useful notion of
permutation invariance,
where we say that a function or a neural
network F is permutation invariant if no
matter what permutation matrix I choose,
the effect of applying the permutation
matrix to the input does not change the
output of function F. Okay?
And you can directly compare this with
the graph with the geometric deep
learning blueprint, where we discussed
these G-invariant layers or global
pooling layers,
which deal with basically satisfying
G-invariance. So, the condition is
exactly the same. We're just now
instantiating it for a very specific
group action and a very specific
collection of features.
Now, of course, this gives you a
necessary condition to build a function
that is resistant to permutations on
sets, but that's not particularly useful
in and of itself if you want to go ahead
and implement a model like this. To
implement a model, you need an actual
model equation. And uh the standard way
in which we build neural networks over
sets is by deploying this model over
here, which is known as the deep sets
model.
So, we compute uh outputs uh over an
input set given by a node feature matrix
X
by first applying uh a learnable
function psi to every single uh node
feature vector that we have in the set,
and then we sum up the resulting
vectors.
And finally, to predict our outputs, we
use another learnable function phi
applied over the output of the sum. Now,
the critical part of this architecture
is the sum aggregation, right? Because
no matter how I choose to permute the
rows of X, the outcome of summing them
is going to be always exactly the same.
This is the critical idea. The sum is
what we call a permutation invariant
aggregator, and as long as it has that
property that no matter what order you
feed the parameters into the function,
it will give you the same result, it
would work. So, this also means that in
principle, you don't need to use the sum
aggregation. Depending on the context,
you might also use element-wise max or
averaging. All of those functions are
permutation invariant. Depending on the
context, one might work better than the
other, and we'll actually discuss
aggregators in quite a lot of detail
during the second lecture today. But
what's the main takeaway from this is
that generally, I don't want you to
always imagine a sum in there because it
might not always be the optimal way of
aggregating information. And to be more
aligned and generic with what the
geometric deep learning blueprint
prescribes, we're actually going to
replace the sum with this O plus. And
whenever you see an O plus in the
equations that I show you today or
beyond,
I want you to interpret this as meaning
any kind of permutation invariant
operator. So, you could imagine O plus
being replaced with sum, with max, with
average, or anything like that.
Now,
obviously, since you have seen already
the discussion on the geometric deep
learning blueprint in previous lectures,
you will know that invariance is not the
whole story, right?
G invariance is a good idea when you
want to predict an output over the
entire domain, but very often, you
actually want to do predictions at the
level of individual nodes of the domain,
right? So, in this case, you'd still
want to be able to make a prediction for
every single node separately,
and the permutation invariant aggregator
would, in principle, destroy that.
Sometimes, it's possible to recover
individual nodes from the aggregation,
but it's really hard to do. Certainly
much harder than it seems to be. So,
what we want instead for these kinds of
problems where we want predictions over
each element of omega and not over all
of omega itself is to find functions
that don't change the order of the
nodes, right? So, in this case,
permuting the input does change the
output, but it changes it in a
predictable way. Specifically, if you
have a permutation of your nodes, it
doesn't matter if you do it before or
after. And this ensures that you can
still identify every single node output
as you go along. And this basically
leads us to an instantiation of the
blueprint of G equivariance for the
specific case of the permutation group,
and we say that a function f of x, in
this case, this function is capitalized
to denote that it still returns a
matrix,
and we say it's permutation equivariant
if, no matter what permutation matrix P
I choose, it doesn't matter if I apply
the P before
or after applying the function, I'm
going to get exactly the same outcome.
And once again, you can take this
notion of permutation equivariance and
directly compare it with what the GDL
blueprint prescribes for a linear G
equivariant layer, you'll find that the
condition B G of X is equal to G B of X
is exactly the same. We're just
instantiating it specifically for the
case of sets and for the permutation
group.
Now, once again, this is not the entire
picture, and you have seen in previous
lectures this idea of it's not just
enough to be resistant to a particular
symmetry group. Often in practice,
nature will corrupt our data in ways
that go beyond the symmetry group we
thought about. So, in the case of, say,
images and shift transformations, in the
real world, you might get not always a
perfectly shifted image of a house, but
you might get a slightly distorted
picture of a house with these noisy
artifacts, and
basically, you don't want your network
to behave completely radically when it
sees a local distortion like this. We
want our signal to still be stable.
And
we probably saw some aspects of this
discussion in prior lectures, but the
general finding that we also show in our
book is that the way to deal with this
kind of stability and keep the signal
behaving properly is to actually have a
local operation, so something that acts
only around the neighborhood of a
particular domain element,
and then
model larger scale interactions by just
composing these local operations. So,
this is the reason why when you build
convolutional neural networks, for
example, you very often have very small
kernels like 3 by 3 that only look at a
small neighborhood around every pixel,
but then you make them very deep to
allow for modeling
longer range interactions. So, this this
general idea is that we would like to
support some kind of concept of locality
in our layers. And now, you might be
asking yourself, what does this actually
even mean for sets, right?
Well, okay.
One way in which we can trivially
enforce locality when we build an
equivariant set function is just to have
some function psi, which is applied to
every node separately. Okay? This is a
trivial way to achieve locality because
now you're applying it to every node in
an isolated manner.
And then, you can also stack these HI
vectors once you compute them for every
node into a new matrix, and this gives
you the output of the equivariant set
function.
Note that so far, we've been dealing
primarily with these matrix-based
operations, but it's going to be very
useful to also think about the local
effects of each function, and that's why
this HI view is going to be very useful,
especially when we make the move to to
graphs.
And
you know, you might be asking yourself,
what does how does this kind of
generalize further?
Well, first of all, let's recall the
expression for deep sets that I gave you
before,
and you can recognize this equivariant
local function as exactly the component
of deep sets which is applied to every
element in isolation. So, these blue
parts are basically exactly the same
idea.
And basically, looking at the function
for deep sets, you can see that it's a
very direct instantiation of the
geometric deep learning blueprint
because you can imagine the psi function
as the equivariant part, which is then
stacked potentially for multiple layers,
and giving you predictions in every
single set element. And then, in case
you need a prediction on the level of
the entire set, you can reduce it using
this permutation invariant aggregator
and the invariant function phi.
Okay?
And one very important thing to note is
that when we say a set is unordered, we
fundamentally mean it's unordered, and
we assume there are no structural
elements between elements of the set.
So, there are no connections or edges
being assumed. Therefore, this is
actually typically as far as we can get
with sets. We cannot get a better local
function in a pure set
beyond just looking at each set element
in isolation. This is a very important
distinction because the moment you try
to put more nodes into psi other than
just xi,
at that point, you are no longer working
with a set, you're actually assuming
already some kind of a graph structure.
So, that's a very important distinction
to make.
And you might be also wondering, is this
really as far as we can get, right?
Because just to
recap what we've done so far, we've
shown, first of all, that if a function
or a neural network over a set is
useful, then it should be permutation
equivariant or invariant
with respect to the ordering of the
nodes in that set.
I've showed you deep sets as one way of
achieving this permutation invariance by
basically directly following the
geometric blueprint, but you might be
asking yourself, is it actually the only
way?
And
it might come as a bit of a surprise
that for many classes of input sets, the
answer to this question is a very
decisive yes. And what this means is, no
matter what permutation invariant
function you give me and say, "This is a
brand new cool function that models data
on sets," I will always be able to
re-express that function as an instance
of a deep sets model. So, what this
means is a nice piece of mind result
that we can basically always rely on
deep sets when we're dealing with when
we're dealing with set data, and we can
be comfortable knowing that this covers
every possible function which is
permutation invariant that we might want
to build over such sets. Unfortunately,
we don't have enough time in this
lecture to cover the proofs of this in
great detail, but I would highly
recommend you check out the original
deep sets paper from Manzil Zaheer and
others, and also this great follow-up
work from Wagstaff, Fuchs, and Engelka,
which extends the analysis to a
continuous space features.
And one very important point to make is
that at the beginning, I motivated set
structure neural networks as a way to
more principally deal with point cloud
problems in computer vision, and it
should be quite interesting to note here
that
concurrently with the development of the
deep sets model,
basically equivalent model in computer
vision came out, which is known as
PointNet, and it empirically
demonstrated that these kinds of ideas
work really well when you apply them on
point cloud tasks. And nowadays,
PointNet is one of the top cited
computer vision papers. And when you
look at its architecture, it's basically
the same thing as what I just told you
with deep sets. The main difference is
that here they opt to use max pooling
rather than sum pooling.
And also, to show that their network is
universal over sets, they actually apply
a very similar proof strategy to the
deep sets paper. And I'll also mention
that they also talk about some
coordinate transformations, which try to
preserve the points geometry in 3D
space. So, in this case, the set is not
purely unordered. We won't talk about
these transformations very deeply right
now, but later on in the course, we will
talk about GNNs that are aware of these
kinds of spatial geometries, especially
when we talk about manifolds and meshes.
And therefore, it's good to just keep in
mind that whenever your node features
have some three-dimensional or otherwise
coordinate information, you might want
to encode additional symmetries on top
of that.
Okay.
So, throughout the previous slides we
covered, we have made a detailed
exposition of learning on sets, showed
these concepts of permutation invariance
and equivariance and how they relate to
learning good set functions.
And specifically,
we have showed that there is this model
called the deep set model, which is
universal. So, any kind of
set function you will ever want to care
about will be expressible using deep
sets. And very conveniently, deep sets
very closely follows our geometric deep
learning blueprint. So, in a way, it's
our first success story of the day.
But,
you might remember that when I initially
started this discussion, I said our
ultimate aim is to learn on graphs. And
I think now that we've built this
mathematical apparatus, we can start to
extend it from sets to graphs. So, now
we will have a domain that doesn't just
have nodes, but also edges connecting
these nodes. So, our graphs will consist
of a set V of nodes and a set E of
edges, which is typically the subset of
the Cartesian product of nodes with
themselves. So, basically, it's a set of
pairs of nodes.
There are many ways in which
we can choose to represent these edges.
Just because we've kind of focused on a
linear algebraic exposition so far, I
will continue using a linear algebra
analogy and I'll say we can express
edges in an adjacency matrix A,
which for now we'll just assume to be a
binary matrix of shape nodes times
nodes, where the entries are either zero
or one depending on whether that
particular pair of nodes is connected by
an edge. There are many other more
efficient ways to represent edges, and
there are also different things you can
attach on the edges like distances or
edge features. Those are all possible.
They do not change the findings, but I'm
deliberately ignoring them for now to
keep the maths a little bit more simple.
Okay? Very important point to note, now
the edges are also part of the domain.
It used to be just nodes, now it's nodes
and edges, so we have to keep track of
two objects.
But, fundamentally,
the main things that we want,
permutation invariance and equivariance,
are still the main things that we want.
In absence of any additional geometric
assumptions over this graph, the only
thing you can really hope to be
resistant to is the ordering of the
nodes that you've chosen. Okay? So,
what's changed really? If you remember
this picture we talked about what is it
that makes a function over sets a
desirable function?
And when we talk about graphs, it's
really exactly the same picture. The
only difference is that now, besides
having these nodes, you also have some
connections between these nodes. And
whenever I permute the nodes, I need to
appropriately permute the edges. So,
when you look at these two graphs here,
you can see, when you stare at them for
long enough, that they're actually
exactly the same graph. I just chose to
present it to you in a different way.
And my permutation invariant function
that acts over this graph should give me
exactly the same result in this case.
So, basically, the concepts are the
same. The ideas are mostly the same.
What's the main difference? Well, now
whenever I apply a permutation to my
nodes, I must also accordingly permute
my edges. And because I said we
represent the edges with an adjacency
matrix, which is of shape nodes times
nodes, we need to permute both the rows
and the columns of this adjacency
matrix. So, when I have a particular
permutation matrix P I want to apply,
this just amounts from a linear algebra
point of view to PAP transpose. You can
do a quick piece of linear algebra to
convince yourselves that this is true.
But, assuming you believe me that this
is true, we can now update our
definitions of invariant and equivariant
functions over graphs. It's basically
the same idea as before. With
invariance, no matter what permutation
we apply to the graph, it shouldn't
change the output. With equivariance, no
matter what permutation we apply to the
graph, it shouldn't matter if we apply
it before or after applying our
function.
So, the main difference here is that now
our function, which used to just take in
node features, now also has to take in
the adjacency matrix. And we assume for
equivariance, for example, that the
edges stay the same and the function
just outputs new node features. So, when
we permute, the output is just P times
the output.
So, hopefully, you'll see how these
concepts are exactly the same as what we
did on sets. We just have to deal with
one extra input to the function.
But, one thing that is markedly
different from sets is this third idea
of locality, right? We said that
locality is a very important property
for a successful geometrically stable
function. And on sets, we really had
nowhere else to go. We could only really
enforce locality by dealing with every
node separately. Okay? But, with graphs,
we have this idea of connectivity
between the nodes. So, we have a more
broad context. We have a node's
neighborhood to guide us in terms of
locality.
And there's many ways to define a
neighborhood, but the most common
standard definition
is to take a one-hop neighborhood of a
node I, which we denote as NI.
And that's basically just the set of all
the nodes J, which are connected to I
with some edge.
And accordingly, once you have the set
of neighbors, you can also extract the
multi-set of all the neighbor features,
which I call XNI. So, it's just really a
collection of all the XJ vectors for all
neighbors J. The reason why we have to
make it a multi-set, note the double
angle bracket, is the fact that that we
could have multiple neighbors with
exactly the same vector, and a set would
destroy this multiplicity. A multi-set
would not destroy that.
And once we have that multi-set of
neighborhood features, we can now define
a local function phi, which acts on a
particular node and the multi-set
neighbors, which gives us a more proper
notion of locality.
And once we can build a function like
that, this phi function,
we can now build permutation equivariant
functions by just taking this phi,
applying it to every node's neighborhood
in isolation, and then stacking the
results together in a resulting node
feature matrix. And
it's almost the whole picture. One
element that is missing is that
phi needs to satisfy another condition,
because phi, as you can see, it takes
this XNI, which is basically a
collection of all the node features of
the neighbors. And clearly, phi should
not depend on the order in which we
choose to present those neighbors,
because then it would be sensitive to
however we chose to permute the
neighbors. So, as long as phi is
permutation invariant in the XNI
argument,
the whole function f of XA is going to
be permutation equivariant. And I think
it's a very important and useful
to try to prove this by yourselves, by
basically expanding this rule and trying
out the definition of equivariance. You
will hopefully derive that if phi is
invariant to permutations of XNI, then f
will be equivariant to permutations.
And now, I realize that there is a lot
of math associated with everything that
I just said, but it's always useful to
take a step back and look pictorially at
what we have achieved, right? Everything
that I've told you about so far amounts
to what you see in this picture. Where
we have a graph with some features XI on
each one of our nodes. And what we
really are just doing is we are taking
those features on the nodes, and we are
updating them to some latent space
features H by taking into account the
features of that node and all the
features of its immediate neighbors,
which are elements of XNI. This is
everything that we've built up so far,
but now we have a very solid
mathematical underpinning for why it was
built in this particular way.
And how can you then use this for
learning on graphs? So, imagine I give
you a graph-structured input with node
features XI and some adjacency matrix A.
We can now apply our permutation
equivariant layers to gradually update
these features to be mindful of the
immediate neighbors. Typically, these
layers do not change the adjacency
matrix, although we will discuss during
our second lecture today
some interesting layers that do change
the adjacency matrix.
And then, what can you do with these
features when you have them? Well, first
of all, if you're interested in
predicting stuff in the individual
nodes, which is known as node
classification, you can learn a
classifier in each one of the nodes
separately. So, this basically allows
you to have an equivariant function
through and through, and you get
predictions for every domain element
separately.
You can also do predictions on the level
of entire graphs, but you need to make
sure that the prediction doesn't depend
on the order of the nodes. So, you
basically need to apply a permutation
invariant tail just as prescribed by the
geometric blueprint. And uh
specifically, you can do exactly the
same thing as the final layer of deep
sets. So, you can aggregate all the HI
vectors together with some permutation
invariant O+ and then compute the output
based on this and this gives you a graph
classifier.
One thing that's quite interesting about
graphs compared to sets is that you also
have this new modality, which is the
edge. And uh often, you can predict
things on edges and you can also predict
whether or not an edge even exist, which
is a setup usually known as link
prediction.
And you can then build a local
equivariant classifier over edges by
just taking the features of the two
nodes that are incident to the edge and
any edge features that you might be
given and based on them having your edge
classifier.
So, this is a general idea of the three
principal tasks that you can do on
graphs.
And okay, so I've told you how to build
a permutation equivariant function on
graphs. You need to specify some local
permutation invariant phi that looks at
features of a node I and all the
features in its immediate neighborhood
and then apply that in a shared manner
to every single neighborhood and then
stacking the results, you get uh a
permutation equivariant function.
Now, you might come across some papers
on graph neural networks and people
write these papers from a variety of
different perspectives.
And these different perspectives like
signal processing, natural language,
computer vision, they all come with
their own uh terminology.
But one thing you can commonly see in
literature is that this capital F is
denoted as a GNN layer.
And the local function phi can be
denoted either by diffusion,
propagation, or message passing
depending on which literature you're
reading.
But I haven't yet told you the key
detail, right? I haven't told you how to
implement the phi.
And needless to say, the implementation
of phi, the local function that
underpins the graph neural network, is a
super intense area of research. In my
opinion, probably one of the most
intense areas of research right now with
uh almost dozens of papers published on
a daily basis.
But fortunately for us, almost all of
these can be classified across three
distinct flavors of uh of uh graph
neural network aggregations. And uh
this can be very useful as you try to
navigate the field and the various
papers published.
Uh in our book, we actually propose this
for the first time that you can look at
the features of a node uh and the
features of all of its immediate
neighbors and aggregate them in three
general ways: convolutional,
attentional, and message passing. As you
go left to right, uh the expressive
power and the capacity of these models
improves. Uh however, the scalability
uh and to some extent the
interpretability might uh become harder.
And I'll just briefly survey these
models before we dive deeper into some
of them for the second lecture.
For convolutional graph neural networks,
the way they work is you upfront decide
on a fixed weight CIJ, which tells you
how much is uh neighbor uh J important
for neighbor I. And uh effectively, you
use these precomputed weights as
coefficients in a weighted sum or
weighted combination across all the
neighbors. You can see the formula here
on the left. So, you apply your update
function phi over the features of the
node itself, XI, and the aggregated with
O+ combination of all the neighbor
features with CIJ as the combination
weights. Usually, the way in which you
compute those weights depends directly
on the structure of the graph, either
its spectral or random walk properties,
and the specific way in which you derive
those features gives rise to different
classes of models like Chebyshev
networks, graph convolutional networks,
or simplified graph convolutions.
Because these weights are precomputed
and often they amount to some kind of uh
interesting averaging over the graph,
they're very useful when you're dealing
with homophilous graphs. So, your edges
actually encode a notion of label
similarity.
And the fact that uh they are designed
in this way with fixed co- coefficients
means that you can interpret this
equation as basically a sparse matrix
multiplication for some particular
definition of plus and times. And this
means you can usually highly scale them.
And as a result, especially because most
industrial GNNs uh that you have to work
with are very homophilous. So,
essentially uh you know, if I'm friends
with someone on a social network, it's
very likely that uh you can label me the
same way as my friend. Like friends tend
to think in similar ways.
And as a result, you can just get away
with applying a homophilous averaging
based GNN like this one and scale it up
vastly in an industrial setting. So,
it's very good for scalability and it's
very good when graphs are homophilous
and many graphs in the real world
actually are homophilous.
However, not always is averaging a good
idea. For example, I'm very active on
the social network Twitter and some of
you might already know, often I will
retweet someone who wrote something on
Twitter and sometimes uh I will
completely agree with them, but
sometimes I will completely disagree
with them and go in a very strong rant
about what they wrote. And basically, in
those cases, you don't want to classify
me the same as the person I retweeted
because I actually have a diametrically
opposite opinion to what they have,
okay? So, averaging over all the
neighbors is not always a good idea and
you might actually want to dynamically
learn how much is every neighbor valued.
And this gives us to the this gives rise
to the second class of graph neural
network architectures, the attentional
GNNs, where we replace this previously,
you know, hard precomputed uh
uh scalar CIJ with a learnable scalar
that comes from this uh function A. So,
we have a function A that looks at the
features of the sender node and the
receiver node and computes the scalar
which will be used to weigh the
different neighbors.
And uh if you've looked at some related
models like this, you will know that a
function like this that takes two
vectors and produces a scalar is often
known as an attention mechanism. And as
a result, we call these GNNs attentional
GNNs. There's many interesting classes
of GNNs that use this idea. Uh maybe
some most prominent examples you should
be aware of are the mixture model CNN or
the MoNet, the graph attention network
that we proposed uh at ICLR 2018,
and its most recent incarnation, the
GATv2, which was published at ICLR a few
months ago.
And uh there are many good reasons why
you might want to build a model exactly
like this because it's a nice middle
ground uh
with respect to both capacity, scale,
and interpretability. Why is this the
case? Because now I can dynamically
compute that a neighbor is useless for
my representation and I can assign him a
very low coefficient. So, my edges no
longer needs to explicitly encode
homophily. I don't have to share the
same label as my neighbor uh with a
model like this. However, I'm still
modeling the interaction with only one
scalar per edge, which is still
computationally efficient. Once I
compute my interaction coefficients, it
still reduces to a form of matrix
multiplication. So, it's reasonably
scalable. And also, because now my model
is computing a dynamic coefficient for
every single one of my neighbors, I can
also in some cases interpret what my
network is doing by looking at these
coefficients. Like it will basically
tell me what were the most important
neighbors for making a particular
prediction, which can be quite useful at
some cases when doing science with these
models.
However, note that with the attentional
models, we were still computing a
weighted average uh over all of the
neighbors. The only difference was that
now we were dynamically computing the
coefficients of that weighted average.
But uh in general, for problems where
edges do not just encode a message uh
method of averaging,
you need something more general than
this. And the most general thing you can
do is the sender and the receiver can
collaborate to compute an arbitrary
message vector to be sent across a
particular edge. So, note the main
difference from this uh equation and the
previous one. Previously, we were
aggregating these different psi of XIs.
So, basically, the neighbor features
were aggregated together using the
attention mechanism.
But uh now, we have both the sender node
and the receiver node collaborating to
compute a message vector, okay?
And this general idea has been explored
quite a bit in models like interaction
networks, message passing neural
networks, and the Graph Nets model from
DeepMind. And in a way, you can think of
it as the most generic graph neural
network layer cuz the other ones can be
seen as a special case.
And uh the edges in this model now don't
tell you how to average neighbors.
Rather, they give you a recipe for how
to pass data along the graph and then
the message function psi figures out how
to pass data on the graph. And this kind
of uh this kind of uh additional
parameterization means that this model
is the most potent one, but also can
have problems with scaling up or with
learning effectively. But conversely, it
makes it very ideal for the kinds of
problems where edges are not to be
averaged over, but rather to encode a
complex process. Therefore, these models
are quite popular for computational
chemistry tasks, for reasoning tasks,
and for simulation tasks.
So,
a brief summary of what we've just
covered. We've looked at how you can
take the geometric deep learning
blueprint and deploy it on sets and
graphs. We studied this through the key
notions of permutation invariance and
equivariance, so specializing
G-invariance and G-equivariance to the
specific case of sets and graphs. We saw
how deep sets can be seen as a universal
blueprint for neural networks on sets,
and then we looked at how to extend this
to build permutation equivariant GNNs
and some of their uses. Then,
specifically, I gave you a quick
overview, which we will extend in the
second lecture, on the three flavors of
graph neural network layers,
convolutional, attentional, and message
passing. And I think it's a very good
exercise, if you have some time, to
quickly show that they are in an
increasing order of generality. So, the
convolutional neural networks are a
subset of the attentional ones that are
themselves a subset of the message
passing ones.
What we will see in the second lecture
is to have an exact implementation of a
generic GNN. We'll go through the
GraphNets model of DeepMind. Then, we
will explore in depth the connections
between GNNs, the deep sets model we
just presented, and also the very
popular transformer model.
We will look at graph isomorphism
testing as a method to see how powerful
graph neural networks are, and hopefully
there will also give some insight into
the algorithmic foundations of GNNs.
There are many other aspects of GNNs,
such as spectrally motivated GNNs,
geometric GNNs, and the graph Fourier
transform, which we don't have scope to
cover today, but they will be covered in
some of the future lectures, especially
as they touch upon manifolds.
And that was actually my last slide.
Thank you so much for listening, and
I believe we have maybe about 10 minutes
for any questions you might have. Thank
you.
Yes, thank you. Thank you, Keita.
So, there are some questions in on
Campuswire. The first question,
so I think it's about
permutation equivariance.
He said,
"Which operator are we using between P
and F for this expression P F of X?"
Mhm.
So, could you clarify what the question
is? Cuz I'm not sure I followed.
So, he's in the
permutation equivariance.
Yeah.
He's asking about
"Which operator are we going to So, are
we using between P and F for this
expression P F of X?"
Right. So, basically, when we say P F of
X, yes, what this means is
you apply the function F over X. This
gives you, since it's equivariant, it
gives you a node feature matrix, right?
Which is of shape nodes times features.
And then you multiply that matrix with
P, okay? So, here F is a function, and P
is a matrix, which is applied to the
output of that function by just matrix
multiplication.
Okay.
The next question,
so I think
The next question is, "Are there three
flavor of
GNN layers based on oriented graph?"
Uh so, I assume here by oriented graph
you're referring to directed graphs,
like graphs where
the edges can point in a particular
direction. Yes.
So,
one thing that's very important to note,
this is a very common question we get,
is if you look at the function here,
right? And if you look at the functions
of the three flavors that are all
outlined here,
I am nowhere actually explicitly
mentioning
whether or not edges are oriented, okay?
All I have is this NI, which is the
neighborhood of all the nodes that are
sending to node I, right? So, to be able
to instantiate each of the three
flavors, all you need is to specify the
neighborhoods of each node, right? How
you choose to specify them is up to you,
okay? So, if a graph is directed, you
may choose to define NI to be all the
nodes that are sending into that node,
or you may choose to make the edges
symmetrical, and if I points to J, make
J point to I as well, okay? This is a
design decision you need to make, but
once you've made that decision, these
flavors will work directly. So, there is
nothing in these equations that is
specific to undirected graphs. I guess
that's all I want to say.
Yeah, okay. The next question,
"What is the SOTA in G GNN layers?"
What is the state of the art in graph
neural network layers? Uh
it's a
it's a very interesting question,
and it really depends on what problem
you're solving, right? So, we will talk
in the second lecture about what are the
most powerful GNNs in terms of
expressive power, and how we can make
them even stronger than that. So, you'll
have to wait for the next lecture to
talk about the theoretical boundaries of
what they can do. When it comes to
actual performance on tasks, it really
depends on the task. So, for some
problems, even the convolutional GNNs
will perform the best, even though they
are theoretically the least powerful,
and that is because the graphs are
highly homophilous, and it has very low
parameters, so it can actually learn
much better in practice, okay?
And actually, when the edges are highly
homophilous, like when your neighbors
really tell you a lot about your own
label, then it has been shown by this
SGC model that I'm referencing here,
that you don't even need deep learning
to beat state of the art, right? You
only just need to repeatedly average
across your neighbors, average, average,
average your features, and then at the
end just have a logistic regression or
some shallow neural network to classify
the nodes. So, all of this extra deep
learning stuff, like the psi's, the
phi's, the activation function, in some
cases you can even completely get rid of
that if your graph is highly
homophilous.
As the graphs get more heterophilous, so
as the edges become more of a
you know,
unclear whether they match the same
label or not, then attention starts to
become more important, and we will
discuss, obviously, all of this in the
context of the transformer as well in
the second lecture.
But, when you move on towards these
chemistry, reasoning, and simulation
problems, then you really want a model
like this for the state of the art. So,
there's a good reason why we have three
flavors. The state of the art is very
much problem dependent right now. I hope
this answers the question.
Yes. The next question,
Khadija is asking about
the concept of link prediction. Could
you give some real application?
Yes, of course. So, that's that's a very
good question. So, I'll just go back to
the slide where we introduced link
prediction. Uh basically, I think it's
going to be one of the most important
industrial problems in future times
because it relates quite heavily to
knowledge graph inference. So, what does
this mean? Basically,
in a knowledge graph, you have something
that represents all the knowledge in the
world that you're modeling, and
obviously that knowledge is incomplete.
You won't have access to all the
possible pieces of knowledge.
So, it might be very important to infer
new possible links inside this knowledge
graph, so that you can more accurately
drive decision making, and one very
common example is in biology. So, you
might have a knowledge graph of drugs
and which diseases they're able to
treat, and if you have a powerful link
predictor in this setting, you're then
going to be able to predict what are
some other diseases that existing drugs
can treat, and therefore you can
repurpose drugs that were maybe
initially uh targeted for something like
diabetes to be used as an antibiotic.
So, I think the potentials, especially
in biology, are quite huge of link
prediction models.
Cuz you can imagine, basically, drugs
and diseases as nodes in a graph. You
connect them together if we use drug A
to treat disease B, but then if we
figure out new links in this graph, we
figure out what are some additional
diseases that this drug could treat.
Um
Yes.
The next question,
um
"What is psi of X computing?"
Mhm. Mhm.
Yeah. So, basically, psi of X, I
believe, well, it's referred to many
times, but
I guess one of the first places we saw
it was in learning on sets here.
Um so, basically, this psi is some
function that takes features and outputs
latent features. So, it's like you know,
a multi-layer perceptron, the simplest
kind of deep neural network you can
build. So, what's its purpose? Well,
basically, its purpose is to take your
input features and map them to some
representation that is non-linear, and
it will be useful for solving the
downstream problem, right? Uh especially
in the case of deep sets, such that when
you aggregate all of those features
together, you'll get something that from
which you can very quickly predict the
label for that particular set using the
function phi, and the role is quite
similar in the case of graphs. The The
only difference here is that uh you have
a function that transforms each neighbor
in isolation to compute some features,
and then you use those neighbor
representations to be aggregated
together, either with fixed weights CIJ,
or with learnable weights with the
attention mechanism. Uh yeah, I hope
this answers the question.
So there's another question. Is it
possible to mix convolutional attention
and message passing as one function but
with a coefficient for each GNN which
specifies is how much it should
contribute to the GNN?
Uh that's a great question
and I don't think anybody tried this. So
if you want to if you're on the lookout
for a research project this can be a
good idea.
But yeah, I think in principle it can be
a pretty good idea because if done
properly it might help you decide up
front which of the three classes of
model you should be using for your
problem because that's actually one big
issue now, right? I give you a brand new
graph data set unless you have a very
deep intuition about the problem you
typically cannot immediately say which
of these three models is the best one to
use, right? So having some kind of a
combined architecture that looks at all
three of them could be quite
interesting. Once again, note that and
as I asked you to do in this exercise
the message passing is the most general
so you can use it to express the other
two. So technically what you'll build is
still a message passing architecture but
presumably if trained in the right way
it might help you pick apart what's the
best inductive bias to use. So yeah,
that is definitely true.
Okay, so I believe we're now past the
hour so we should probably stop here and
we can continue again well we can
continue offline to talk about questions
on campus wire if you agree and then we
can you know reconvene for the second
lecture and talk more about these
models.
Okay. Thank you, Victor.
Perfect.
Thank you all so much. I hope you
enjoyed it and I can't wait to see you
again in
in one hour time.
Thank you.
Yes, thank you.